hello again uh we are having some
difficulties hopefully it's a little bit
better now is this thing on
since uh this will be this side of the
stream again I'm Jess this is serene
we're playing obscure I didn't know
there was a garden behind this I know
that I I do like when Oh protagonists
speak yeah Oh mrs. [ __ ] it's good at me
siggi tape can be used to join two up
and stand on this highlights reel is
gonna be like occasionally even mean
occasionally ads on sorry it's a gun
that shoots torches at college it's
freaking creepy man is he like I did
this randomly decide on a whim to come
down yeah like I couldn't get out of the
gym so I just came down him oh hi pity
no I hope you're that guy did John is
awesome we gotta get you outta here
quick
why he's like I didn't listen to you I'm
a joke here just a skinny nerd the free
shoot
can you play oh I don't want me this
Scylla guy thing hey guy I'm the buff
tan wanna be the bump town in here see
you got a gun okay so you're gonna take
the lead oh jesus Mick [ __ ] no I'm
trying I told you on it I'm shining I'm
shining I'm shining protecting me leave
without me wow these kids wellies
children these days oh yeah that was an
upskirt was it what are you wouldn't his
parents be the ones to do 613 p.m. the
scariest of times do you want to be here
yeah sure I'll be this one is that
friendly fire okay you do it then if you
could do that at any point today that
would be just right
okay I'm sure you can teach me not oh oh
violence solves everything Wow hold them
cold drinks that's a Gloucester you know
what that means in this room please okay
okay if we could find out that we oh I'm
gonna medium bookshelf maybe I should
I'm trying to make my moped queer unting
noises yeah I can see it I can see it
underneath your feet Jamie oh [ __ ] I
don't think I can do it I think I think
you have all the items and stuff I think
I'm just an extra okay so I mean if the
cameras following you know oh god yeah
what are you what the [ __ ] what's Oman
protect me protect me I can't see I
can't see it's like real house of ours
oh my god that's my places up against
Jamieson
I'm sorry I'm sorry Stan's a total
bonehead [ __ ] Stan thank you stinky
must open some old door around here that
must be it
oK you've got camera control
again sorry I'm sorry
oh yeah diabete I'm in my medical Syria
oh my god I am I'm a genius I'm self
defense well I'm so hanging hanging back
so far you won't even see me anymore oh
[ __ ] they're too fast oh my god oh that
one got me in the back
I'll follow you okay Oh cutscene
I guess was supposed to run oh [ __ ] just
like I'm running with the stitch oh you
an alum anyone who looks like dad what
are you doing something wrong why
haven't you seen in the hallways all the
monsters creeping around we stand
oh I'm standing now oh cool what's his
ability but took three paper cups that
should be enough two paper cups cut same
time doo-doo-doo-doo-doo we need to
elevator music someone's saying get
ready thanks yeah 28 how long ago did I
say
it's okay I am now that go you can do it
Jess I believe in you look at me I'm
running around in circles you know you
want to chase off to me Oh what cool I
didn't have to do that you saved me and
my inappropriate underwear I wanna be
the guy down I want to be skatey dude
Hazel's there's more I'm a rebel without
a car so that's too bad oh it wants me
to shoot I don't think we can get
actually [ __ ]
oh yes being on it
obey me in the head what is that oh
actually now this is good this is ten
wag this is Ricky keep on doing it oh we
went to go see how that bar okay okay
it's really you know it's teh plan they
call it we did just play obscure I think
this is a game probably try and play
again I really wanted nice to be able to
play again the two of us instead of week
on week stopping out um so yes hopefully
this has not been too unbearable if
you're watching it live but if you want
to grab it it's out on Steam
not just PlayStation so that's kind of
cool be sure and leave us all your
thoughts in the youtube comment box or
on GameSpot comments where I'll be
putting out the highlights reel in a day
or two and yeah HOH live hashtag on
Twitter if you are so inclined thanks
everyone for joining us next week bye